good morning it's seven o'clock this is
sky news breakfast
top stories for you today going for gold
china wins the first medal
of the tokyo olympics
britain's mass park events restart for
the first time
since lockdown began england sees full
music festivals and busy nightclubs for
the first time since the easing of
restrictions
i'm feeling good but i'm scared because
we know what's coming next
clover's coming next
extremely concerned police appeal for
information about an 11 year old girl
who left a home in bolton and traveled
to london
get your freedom back gareth southgate
urges young people to get their vaccine
for seven days in a row we've seen
temperatures up to 30 degrees celsius
across the uk
but today the heatwave comes to an end
with thunderstorms in the south
all the details coming up shortly
and at quarter two we'll take through
the papers with the journalist pradesha
and the deputy editor of spiked
tom slater
[Music]
morning to you the first medals have
been awarded at the tokyo olympics
china took the honours with gold in the
women's 10 meter air rifle
so far no medals for team gb but in
rowing
helen glover qualified for the
semi-finals in the women's pair
as she goes for a third gold medal our
sports correspondent tom parmenter
reports from tokyo the first gold medal
of these games went to china
in the women's 10 meter shooting shona
macintosh from edinburgh
only finished 12th and missed out on the
final
in the rowing helen glover is back she's
had three children since her gold in rio
she and polly swan finished third in
their heat and are into the semi-finals
last night japan tried to find the right
tone in their
opening ceremony respecting the pandemic
while finally welcoming the world to
their games
it's been a long hard road but finally
tokyo is ready to light the way out of a
pandemic
right up until the last seconds they
protested outside
[Music]
others came to the roads around the
stadium just to feel
their home olympics almost everyone else
watched at home
this is as close as they'll get
the paired back parade was a gathering
from all corners of the world
the organizers think they are all
covered free
you are true olympic athletes
watching all this here in tokyo is now
actually no different to watching it
anywhere else in the world it's only on
tv you can
join in on your smartphone and tap and
clap away and cheer but
it's not the same as it but it is still
the olympic games
still the pinnacle for so many of our
athletes when you go through tough times
with people
you realize how much hard graft they've
put in and to now be here
be in tokyo training on the pitch it's
all coming true
um i think that's really special in a
moment that we all need to embrace
because
we've had a lot of hard work to get here
and actually now it's just a fun bit
team gb's star sprinter dina asha smith
was a games maker volunteer back in
london 2012.
her moment comes into games when podium
protests will still
cause controversy but the rules on
taking the knee
have been relaxed if somebody does
decide to take a knee and it was still
banned i
couldn't understand how the irc was
actually going to enforce that
in terms of would you take away
somebody's medal would you penalize
somebody for being against racism
like how on earth was that ever going to
go down
japanese tennis star naomi osaka was
given the crowning moment
but nobody knows how these games will
play out
it is a global experiment that's now
live
well tom's in tokyo for us this morning
so how's it going on day one tom
not a sparkling start yet by team gb
stephen but the games
are very much coming thick and fast now
the road race is on at the moment
going through some very hilly stretches
around the foothills of mount fuji
spectacular backdrops
team gb riders had a bit of a crash
early on
uh garand thomas and tau kagan hart
clashed wheels with an
austrian it was a bit messy but they're
back up on their bikes and
riding through pretty tough conditions
with the heat and humidity
but they've got a bit of work to do to
really challenge the leaders in there in
the tennis we've seen andy murray
win his first doubles match with joe
salisbury beating a french pair
6-3 6-2 and heather watson sadly is out
in the first round
she lost to a german in the first round
she's our only
female competitor in the tennis after
johanna conte had to pull out due to her
coronavirus test
quite a few days ago now in the boxing
we will see medals i guarantee that
through these games we'll see debuts
today
for karis artings store from
macclesfield in cheshire she's fighting
at botswanan
at 9 15 uk time and peter mcgrail from
liverpool very popular scouser on the
boxing team
he's very hotly tipped for a medal as
well and he will be going up against a
thai boxer at around 10 o'clock
uk time so there are lots of metal hopes
they will come
further down the line and they're
getting ready in your toxita in
staffordshire
this morning because their man adam
petey is in the pool for one of his
heats at lunchtime
he of course is the world record holding
breaststroke
superstar and he's won plenty of medals
before but he's looking to break world
records again
in these games it would be a huge
surprise if adam petey doesn't win gold
in these olympic games and his nan
mavis has been tweeting again she was
something of a star in previous games as
well
saying good morning everybody well this
is it let's enjoy the olympics 2020
so that is the word from you toxita in
staffordshire as they wait for their man
adam peaty in the pool but uh not not
the tight the
that's brilliant start from team gb that
we were hoping for but i'm
i'm suspecting really that that will
change pretty quickly
okay tom thank you now the mass
participation parkrun events restart
this morning for the first time since
march last year
the weekly five kilometer run takes
place in more than 500 locations across
britain
when we last delivered part one in
england in march
2020 i think we'd gone 16 and a half
years without missing a weekend
and now we've missed 70 saturdays in a
row
so it's good to be back this morning it
means such an incredible amount to be
able to
to reopen today you know we over the
last 17 years parkland has had the most
amazing impact on people's health and
well-being and our mission statements to
make the world healthier and happier
well across england major public events
and gatherings have resumed following
the easing of restrictions
large-scale music festivals are taking
place this weekend and nightclubs are
reopened
but it comes as more than six hundred
thousand people have been told to
isolate by test and trace
our correspondent shaman freeman powell
reports
all glammed up and ready to enjoy
freedom weekend
clubbers across england queued outside
of clubs for the first time
in almost 18 months
i'm feeling good but i'm scared because
we know what's coming next
clover's coming next but um it's
important for our mental health
to you know go out there but i do agree
it's the wrong thing to do
i'm scared basically she's not the only
one that's concerned
these celebrations come with caution as
over half a million people
are being forced to self-isolate in the
latest pandemic the pandemic is because
we have a pandemic
and this is the first time really that
we have been on an upward curve and
upward trajectory
so it is inevitable that a large number
of people
will be being asked to isolate
this weekend also sees latitude festival
welcome
thousands of music lovers under a
government event safety trial
people here also have the chance to grab
a jab in between
a lot of them are coming back towards
the end of the weekend they don't want
to have the side effects during the
festival
it's a relief for them especially with
the new guidelines that they want
everyone to be double vaccinated so they
can go into nightclubs and i think
that'll be you know spread across a
wider where you need two doses
back in central london clubbers were
over the moon to be back on the dance
floors again
but if revellers don't take a cautious
approach to their rediscovered freedom
these pubs and clubs
may have to close again shimane freeman
powell
sky news police say they're extremely
concerned about an 11 year old girl
who's disappeared from her home in
bolton
fatima cadilla is understood to have
travelled to london
in the early hours of yesterday morning
let's talk to melania veselninovic who's
in the newsroom for us what more do we
know molena
well police say that fatima left her
parents home in bolton at some
point after 7 30 pm on thursday she went
to bolton train station
where the police say she came into
contact with an unknown
man and a woman they appeared worried
for her
they were on the same train as she was
to manchester piccadilly station
and then on to birmingham new street
station now the police say that fatima
arrived at london houston station alone
at 1 13 am on friday but they would like
to trace
this man and woman and speak to them
because they believe that perhaps she
had spoken to them about where she was
headed
once she was in london now
understandably
fatima's family are distressed they
released a statement through the police
read out here by detective chief
inspector paul rollinson
fatima we miss you you're not in any
trouble
and we want you to come home we want
to at least know you're safe and again
you're not in any trouble
please contact us direct or the police
we're in a
state of shock we really want to know
where she is
who she's with but most of all that
she's just safe
fatima please come home
the last cctv images of fatima show her
leaving houston station but there had
been sightings of her
around london bridge tube station which
leads the police to believe that she may
still be
in that area and they're appealing to
anyone with any information
to come forward okay milano thank you
now the government's continuing to face
pressure over its pledge to fix
the social care crisis age uk is written
to the prime minister
two years after boris johnson took
office and promised to outline a plan
to reform adult care well let's talk to
the head of external affairs at age uk
hannah pierce good to see you this
morning and what would you have
liked to see happen in that two-year
period
well we were really pleased when boris
johnson promised to fix care once and
for all
when he became prime minister two years
ago
today um but here we are two years on um
still waiting for his plan and it just
doesn't feel like the government
understands the urgency of the issue
even after the tragedies that we've seen
in the social care sector
and due to code within this past year
i mean i was going to say i mean it
doesn't help your case
whatsoever but i mean there is an
argument isn't there to say well
you know all these sort of issues we're
going to take a back seat over the last
18 months as
as unfortunate as that is
yeah i mean we know it's a very
difficult issue it's a very
expensive issue but it's a really
important issue and we're
really hopeful that the prime minister
can keep his promise to fix
care um we found from our research that
there have been 1.4 million requests for
care from older people
um in the two years since the prime
minister made his promise to fix
care that have been turned down so
that's around 14
000 people a week who've contacted their
local authority to get help for care or
2 000 people a day who have asked for
care and being turned down and this
isn't the fault of local
councils they can only provide care for
someone if they have the funding
and and the staff to do the job so we
really do need
um the prime minister to keep this
promise we understand it's been a really
really challenging time due to covet
um but you know two years on we really
feel it's time for him to come up with
with a plan to reform and fund social
care properly people rely on it
and we've been talking about this for
decades haven't we why is this such a
difficult
problem for the politicians to solve
well it's it's a it's a huge problem we
know that there are 1.5 million older
people who aren't getting care
that they need at the moment and
hundreds of thousands
of older and disabled people who are
likely to need care we know that
because of covert people have in a way
that their disabilities and illnesses
have been
accelerated because they haven't been
they haven't had the help that they've
they've needed over the past year and we
know that lunch clubs and day centres
have closed so people who
who were um managing with a bit of help
who have now been struggling on their
own and have got to the point where
they've needed to
approach their local authority to sort
out some kind of social care package and
then they found that it's not there
but but what i'm wondering hannah is
because
successive governments have tried to
tackle this
and not made any real headway why is
successive government spreading on this
what is it about the issue that makes it
so difficult to solve
i think it's the funding um there isn't
agreement on on how to fund it we've had
successive governments you're right you
know for
ten years ago we had the landmark dilma
commission report
commissioned by the coalition uh
government we thought that that was a
hopeful um
chance for reform that didn't happen and
we've had since then
six social care ministers four
secretaries of state for
health and social care all who have
promised to reform social care and yet
here we are um
without any reforms coming forward there
that
we need to have cross-party agreement on
the issue but it's
it's a very it's a very difficult issue
and it involves a lot of funding but
politics is about priorities and and we
felt that the
prime minister had chosen this as a
priority
and we really hope that he's able to
deliver on that promise
and as you say though with every passing
day
you're looking at what 2000 people or so
not getting the funding
that they need so i mean this this
really is a case where
every day does count it does my
overriding message to the prime minister
is that there's a very
human cost um to these repeated delays
and the price is being paid by those
people who
who desperately need care reform
okay hannah pierce from age uk good to
talk to you thank you
thank you now the family of a british
hiker who's been missing in the pyrenees
have been told that police have found
possible human remains
close to where she went missing 37 year
old esther dingley had been walking
alone in the mountains near the spanish
and french border
and was last seen in november
the england manager gareth southgate has
joined a campaign encouraging people to
get vaccinated against coronavirus
in the video message he was asking
younger people especially to get the jab
so they can have their freedom back
a truck driver has survived after this
bridge collapse during severe flooding
in eastern russia
reports say more than 650 homes have
been flooded
five bridges have been washed away
during extreme downpours
in the zabakhalsk region
now this weekend sky news will host a
half hour climate special featuring
all the coverage of the extreme weather
recently you can see it today and
tomorrow here on sky news
first showing at half past eleven this
morning
well let's see what the weather's going
to do for you today here's joe
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
hello good morning to you well yesterday
of course we had an extreme heat warning
for ireland
and today we have warnings out for much
of england and wales for thunderstorms
so it's quite a different day that we're
waking up to
good deal of cloud here in lincolnshire
along with many other
eastern counties much of that should
burn back and certainly for scotland for
ireland
and northern parts of england it will be
another mostly fine day
with some sunshine and temperatures into
the 20s
perhaps maxine is around 29 degrees
south is for ireland so it's still very
warm there
but it's a very different story further
south we've seen heavy
thundering rain spreading its way up
from the southwest it's currently lying
roughly in a line from cardiff and
bristol
down towards the southeast the southeast
in particular seeing some
widespread thunderstorms a lot of uh
lightning thunder some large hail mixed
in gusty winds as well
really unpleasant driving conditions not
particularly nice weather
anyway well that line of thunderstorm is
going to move its way into central areas
and parts of east anglia before it
eventually starts to die away
and then we'll just see further
thunderstorms developing in the south
so uh yeah some pretty unpleasant
weather around today and as i say
warnings out for those temperatures in
the low 20s for most
28 or 29 the high
now in hungary the law is officially
called the children
protection act but there's little doubt
over who it's really targeting
angry's prime minister wants depictions
of gay lifestyles and transgender issues
outlawed in schools victor orban's new
law
and a referendum designed to confirm it
have put him at odds with the eu
one activist told sky news he may have
to leave the country
from budapest our europe correspondent
adam parsons reports
there is little sign that the city is
about to host its pride celebration
no banners few posters and hardly any
rainbow flags
it's supposed to be a focal point for
fun
but for many in hungary's lgbt plus
community
this is a worrying and divisive time
prime minister victor orban has just
driven through laws to restrict what he
calls
homosexual propaganda the depiction of
lgbt plus characters in school books or
television programs his supporters say
it is a move to protect
family values it's not a human right for
lgbti activists
to be in schools it's not their right to
educate
children about their lifestyle
lifestyles are for adults to make
and they are free to make whatever
choice they want to
to choose when they are adults but when
kids are at school we need to protect
them
mr orban will hold a referendum on the
issue next year the government
has put up inflammatory posters across
the city this one reads
do you fear for your child about sexual
propaganda
emmett is a transgender teenager he says
he's angry
and uncertain i i really hope that it's
not
gonna get worse
uh deeply i i feel like
i should run for my life out of here
because it will get worse so why
is all this happening now victor orban
is facing a parliamentary election
next year and he thinks he's at his best
when fighting
an enemy first it was migrants then the
roma now he seems to have picked on the
lgbt plus community
as his bogeyman what's more he is
getting slated by
eu leaders but mr orban's calculation is
that the more grief he gets from
brussels
the more support he'll get from
hungarian voters
the genesis of this new political battle
was probably sparked by people like dora
duro a far-right mp who publicly
destroyed a book of fairy tales
because it contained gay characters
from the political heart of this city
there's now a growing tide of discontent
some will call it bigotry mr orban
says he's defending his nation's culture
adam parsons sky news budapest
well a little bit of disappointment for
team gb
on the first day of the olympics having
been tipped for a medal
showed a mcintosh failed to qualify for
the final round
of the women's 10-meter air rifle well
olympic program manager of british
shooting alex ballard
joins us now good to see you this
morning oh what a shame
for shona what went wrong do you think
yeah
morning stephen i think you know um it's
it's a tough event it's a it's a really
tough event and the margins forever
ferreira in these in these precision
rifle competitions are so
small and just to put it into context
she's shooting um
at the target and the 10 in the center
that she's really aiming for
it's just the size of a full stop so
it's it's really tough
in a very very competitive field so i
think you know
we we reflect this morning we're all
blurry-eyed as shooting fans because we
were up late into the night but we
reflect with a lot of pride it was a
strong performance from her
to finish 12th actually she was just
over a point away from the final
and i think you know it's it's it's
she's the first
athlete out the team gb that could win a
medal so there's that extra pressure
and really for shona this is her this is
her second event
her main event so to speak is next
weekend in the three positions rifle so
i think
disappointment yes but we're really
proud of her
for her pictures
yeah i'll keep you your lines breaking
outside alex we'll
we'll keep trying is she is she the sort
of character has she got the resilience
to then
take this on board and push even harder
for the next event
absolutely um you know anybody who knows
shona will know what a what a steely
character she is and what a fighter she
is and
you know she's done a lot of work um on
her sort of psychological
preparation and psychological ability in
sports she's got a fantastic team around
her in tokyo and actually i think she'll
pure reflect on this and she'll pick
herself right back up and she'll go
again
very very strongly next weekend i mean
how are we in
in other prospects moving forward i mean
because we've done quite well haven't we
previously
in in the shooting at previous olympics
i mean have we built up a strong team
this year
yeah absolutely so um you know five
years ago in rio we won
we won two medals in in the shotgun
disciplines and we sent a really strong
shotgun team again in in those
competitions so we've got
the likes of matthew coward holly who's
coming into this olympics as uh as a
world and european champion so he's
he's riding high and he's joined by um
aaron heading who's won multiple world
medals over the years
um and kirsty bar who's who's very
similar so it's a it's a really strong
shotgun team for the events that start
on wednesday um
we're really excited about what they can
do and we've got the new mixed teams
format
on saturday where matthew and kirsty
will be going together
um with a really strong chance of a
medal there as well so
yeah prospects are good for for more
success for shooting and for team gb
as lovely as rex submiss alex you must
be disappointed not to be out there
yes as i as i look out my window it's
it's the grey skyline of wrexham and not
the the
lovely pictures of the tokyo skyline
that i've been being sent by
the guys on the ground out there but
we're here for the second round of the
british championship so
actually there's a athletes
i'm going to be seeing today who will no
doubt be the names that perhaps we're
talking about in just three years time
in paris so
it's all good it's not quite the same
but it's still all good
okay look alex really good to talk to
you this morning thank you thank you
now a record 618 000 people were last
week told to self-isolate by the nhs
kovidap
for many low-paid workers quarantined of
course hits them in the pocket
one restaurant worker in south isolation
told us that
he'd had to borrow money ashley harinag
went to meet workers hit by the
so-called
pindemic in brighton
in the week of newfound freedoms
self-isolation alerts are plaguing
brighton's maze of independence shops
repeated notifications for jewellery
maker natasha
meant taking swift action she's deleted
the nhs app completely
with the amount of stress that
businesses have gone under
i don't think it's very fair for
everyone to have to
do it otherwise literally everyone will
be in isolation the whole time when we
don't
actually have covert the exemptions list
is designed to tackle the most urgent
issues posed by the pandemic but there
are countless businesses
who after 16 months of uncertainty are
finally able to find their feet again
only now
to face more disruption the consensus
among many is it's not fair
whilst critical workers are relieved
today for the many sectors left out like
retail and hospitality
they're contending with potential staff
shortages and a loss in revenue
it's katie's first day back at work
after 13 days in self-isolation
she struggled mentally and financially
and believes both
could have been avoided in my opinion as
long as you know that you don't have
covid and you're not living with anyone
that has covert for me i see no reason
why you shouldn't keep coming into work
because for me
the app is so flawed because it's done
by bluetooth so
i could live next door to someone who
has covered and i could get pinged
for the self-employed or those like greg
on a zero hours contract
self-isolating also means a sudden cut
to their paycheck
i've lost a lot of money to covid um
i i've had to like unwillingly borrowing
money off my mother
um to pay my rent um as i'm i'm quite
deep in my overdraft at the moment
so yeah financially i've been hit quite
hard
the app is seen as one of the
government's key tools for ensuring
public safety
from the 16th of august the double
jabbed a free from its clutches
until then daily testing in place of
isolation
feels like a luxury that these workers
can only dream of
ashnaharenak sky news in brighton
well this is sky news breakfast let's
see what the weather's going to do for
you today
with joe
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
hello there good morning to you well i
can't say it's all change
uh but parts of the country are seeing a
big change yesterday of course we got an
extreme heat warning out
for northern ireland uh with
temperatures for the seventh day running
topping 30 degrees celsius
today and tomorrow we've got warnings
out for thunderstorms and those
thunderstorms have already arrived and
those in the south probably know all
about it
they've spread in from the southwest
overnight currently lying in a line from
the cardiff bristol area down towards
the southeast it's the southeast
which are being hit hardest by these
thunderstorms we're looking at
frequent lightning and thunder large
hail
gusty winds and torrential downpours uh
flash flooding is a very real risk as we
go through the day
so that line of thunderstorms is
actually moving its way northwards it'll
get as far as central areas
and east anglia before it starts to die
out but
further thunderstorms will follow into
the south so not much respite from that
meanwhile for scotland ireland northern
parts of england
there is some cloud over eastern
counties that will burn back through the
day
and then you're looking at more sunshine
and whilst it will be a little bit
cooler than it has been for many parts
of the country we're still looking at a
high of 28 or 29 degrees celsius for
ireland
time for the papers then this morning
with the journalist pradesha and the
deputy editor of spiked
tom slater good to see you both again
badisha can we kick off
um with the times looking at covert
rates
yeah i know that every time we're on
here and we talk about perfect rates
it's like we're the harbingers
of bad news or at least shocking news so
the headline is really quite startling
one in
75 now have covert that cases are
reducing
so we know that the facts are there are
weak on weak rises in
new cases hospitalizations and deaths
and in the last 24 hours there have been
36 000 new cases but
the rate of growth is slowing so it's
still
growing but less quickly than it was in
the previous
few days maybe even the last week or two
but if you want to do a comparison
the rates of new infections cases and
hospitalizations
is at the highest they've ever been
since february now
time has glommed into one big uh gray
mess in the last
um 18 months or so but february was
really
more than a season ago and it was seen
as a critical time then the controversy
here which actually this article doesn't
touch upon is
people who are asking including sage the
government's own advisers
what is the government's strategy is the
government rolling out some kind of
stealth heard immunity strategy where
they're waking waiting for the pandemic
to burn itself out to work through the
population particularly now of
younger people who are getting it and so
it will then
pass naturally once we have the
necessary antibodies
the government aren't saying that that's
what their strategy is
but that's exactly what it seems to be
and that's exactly where
the russian the argument is because it's
very difficult to discern the
government's
own tactics within this pandemic have
they taken their eye off the ball
is there a long-range plan or is there
no plan at all
another shocking statistic to give you
is that a significant proportion of the
people who are currently
in hospital around 30 have had
both of their vaccine jabs now what you
have to take from this is not that
vaccines don't work
but that if there wasn't a generally
successful vaccination program that
proportion
would be worse so jenny harry is one of
the main figures speaking out as
an authority figment the pandemic has
actually said look this
shows us if we look at the data that
it's very important to get
both of your vaccine jabs one dose
doesn't do it
two gives you better protection that
doesn't mean that
you definitely won't get it you
definitely won't be hospitalized but it
does mean that your protection is higher
but
it's extremely sobering news and it's
very hard to keep it all in your head
because we really are 18 months into
this
and me including it's very very wearing
but i do think that the facts are in
front of us now
yeah we can't take our foot off the
pedal just yet i don't think
um to the eye tom looking at taking the
knee at the olympics
yes so the whole taking the knee
controversy has read its head again in
relation to
olympics so this i story reporting on
the comments made by
dean asher smith the great british
sprinter the fastest
recorded british women in history no
less who
has said that the ioc the international
olympics committee
should not punish any athletes who
choose to take the knee or make similar
political statements specifically on the
podium there has already been some
softening of the rules so the team gb
women footballers
have been given permission to do the
pre-match gesture in line with what the
men's team have been doing
but there is still this prohibition on
the podium and the ioc saying that the
podium
is sacrosanct now i i think athletes
should be able to make whatever
political statements
they choose to make of course i think
clamping down on it
is only really going to cause more
controversy than less
but at the same time i think you know in
a way i think people presume that these
gestures are
much more edgy and controversial they
actually are i mean ashley smith draws a
comparison with 1968 and tommy smith and
john carlos you know raising
the black power salute on the medal
stand at mexico
but at the same time i think we're in a
very different world now you know
certainly
racism is not as it was in 1968 in a lot
of western countries
but also when smith and carlos made that
gesture you know they were hounded out
of athletics for it was a very edgy
thing
to do they got an awful lot of flak and
threats and all the rest of it whereas
now i think in a lot of sports taking
the knee you'll be applauded by the
great and good for doing this so i think
you can't really keep politics out of
sport i think that's a complete misnomer
i just wish we could kind of keep
the culture war out of sport i'd settle
for that but nevertheless
let athletes say what they're gonna say
let people criticize them that seems
like a better
fit than to just put prohibitions on
these things yeah yeah okay to the
express prediction looking at
social care you know would still haven't
made any
any significant progress on this
no we haven't i did quickly want to say
i agree with what tom said and i really
appreciate those comments but yes we're
on to social care so
what the last 18 months have done is
really exacerbate
and point out all of the pre-existing
problems we had before and they haven't
gone away but so the scandal of course
here is
long-term under investment in absolutely
vital
social care now that includes support
for emergent new families and kids it
also
includes support for older residents
vulnerable residents and citizens
and all the rest of it at the moment the
government only spends 310 pounds
per person who needs that later life
care and of course
all of the charities who campaign about
this are saying that
that's not good enough two years ago
boris johnson promised that he'd solved
the social care problem
to quote him once and for all and of
course we know that
events overtook us but what this new
study shows is that
up to a quarter of people who are
contacting their local authorities
saying
i need some help i need some support
with day-to-day living
they're actually being turned down and
of course as a cost cutting measure
all of these local authorities have put
in ever more stringent
rules for whether or not you qualify and
there's no appeals process
so if you're denied what you think is
essential social care but you don't meet
all of the criteria
there's no recourse you can't write to
them again
and so on and so forth we know that all
of these these forms of help
from the state have been shrinking and
that this isn't really a two or three
year problem this is
the culmination of years probably even
decades
in this sort of help shrinking but it's
now reached a stage where it's
absolutely critical and of course
covet has made all of those inequalities
much worse
so if you're well off if you have lots
and lots of social help and good
networks
even if you get ill you're going to be
in a better position
relatively speaking than someone who
doesn't have
all of those layers of support yeah a
hugely difficult and complex issue
um let's turn our attention to something
a little bit more fun
uh the latitude festival in the mail
talk i can't work out if you're
you're a festival type or not
probably not anymore in my younger years
potentially but
i've got one booked in a couple of in
next month actually which i was
glad to hear is going ahead um so
latitude fest was part of one of the
pilots
in order to test out full capacity
outdoor festival events
so there's a bit of 40 000 strong crowd
who've descended on hen park in
suffolk for this and it's you know it's
things like this which really do warm
the heart 18 months into the pandemic i
think we had a similar thing when you
saw the crowds in wembley
during the euro 2020 final i know that
was controversial
but there are just certain things that
you cannot do socially distanced and
that's one thing which you know whether
it's big sporting events whether it's
big
musical events you have to be cheap by
jowl it has to be
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of people because that atmosphere you
just cannot recreate
if you're all spaced out two meters
apart so we'll see how this um
pilot goes it seems like a lot of the
pilots so far whether it's night clubs
or
festivals or the rest of it in the
previous months seems to go off broadly
without a hitch
i'm just hoping that we can get back to
those kinds of things as well because it
isn't just about being able to go to the
shops and the pubs again it's also about
being able to do all kinds of things
that just are impossible under the cove
restrictions so yes heartwarming to see
these kinds of scenes i see i've reached
the age where i can't imagine why anyone
would want to go to a festival at all
nice little b b somewhere maybe but
there you go that's just me being a
right old fogey tub
and i tell you what i quite fancy i
quite fancy these little trips to the
edge of space
madison what's the telegraph saying
about jeff bezos
well as jeff bezos and his rival richard
branson i mean what could this possibly
be about stephen really rich competitive
guys that are
literally measuring the size and force
and speed of their rockets
one of them gets 50 miles into space the
other one gets 53 miles into space
the main federal avery aviation
administration body says that if you get
past 50 so you can just blast off from a
field in your back garden or something
then that's it you've gone into space
you've got 50 miles up
and that's it but while jeff bezos and
richard branson were literally spending
billions of pounds trying to do it with
their
ever increasing rockets the faa actually
quietly changed
the rules so bezos and uh branson
are not officially astronauts so they
don't get their blue peter badge
basically you have to meet all of these
other criteria
and you have to be doing something
good to see you both